when we're dealing with basic arithmetic
we see the concrete numbers there we'll
see 23 plus 5 we know what these numbers
are right over here and we can calculate
them it's going to be 28 we can say 2
times 7 we could say 3/4 in all of these
cases we know exactly what numbers we're
dealing with as we start entering into
the algebraic world and you probably
have seen this a little bit already we
start dealing with the ideas of
variables and variables there's a bunch
of ways you can think about them but
they're really just values in
expressions where they can change the
values in those expressions can change
so for example if I write if I write x
plus 5 this is an expression right over
here this can take on some value
depending on what the value of x is if X
is equal to so if X is equal to 1 then
then X plus 5 our expression right over
here is going to be equal to is going to
be equal to 1 because now X is 1 it'll
be 1 plus 5 so X plus 5 will be equal to
6 if X if X is equal to I don't know
negative 7 then then X plus 5 is going
to be equal to well now X is negative 7
negative 7 is going to be negative 7
plus 5 which is negative 2 so notice X
here is a variable X here is the
variable and it's value can change
depending on the context and this is in
the context of an expression you'll also
see it in the context of an equation
it's actually important to realize the
distinction between an expression and an
equation an expression is really just a
statement of value a statement of some
type of quantity so this is an
expression an expression would be
something like what we saw over here X
plus 5 the value of this expression will
change depending on how this what what
depending on what the value of this
variable is and you could just evaluate
it for different values of X another
expression could be something like I
don't know
Plus Z now everything is a variable if Y
is 1 and Z is 2 is going to be 1 plus 2
if Y is 0 and Z is negative 1 it's going
to be 0 plus negative 1 these are these
can all be evaluated and they'll
essentially give you a value depending
on the values of each of these variables
that make up the expression an equation
you're essentially setting expressions
to be equal to each other that's why
they're called equations you're equating
two things an equation you'll see one
expression being equal to another
expression so for example you could say
something like X plus 3 is equal to 1
and in this situation where you have an
equation with the only one where you
have one equation with only one unknown
you can actually figure out what X needs
to be in this scenario and you could
might even do it in your heads what plus
3 is equal to 1 well you can do that in
your head if I have negative 2 plus 3 is
equal to 1 so in this context an
equation is starting to constrain what
this what value this variable can take
on but it doesn't have to necessarily
constrain it as much you could have
something like X X plus y plus Z is
equal to 5 now you have this expression
is equal to this this other expression 5
is really just an expression right over
here and there are some constraints if
you if someone tells you what Y and Z is
and you're going to get an X if someone
tells you what X and Y is and that
constrains what Z is but it depends on
what they what the different things are
so for example if if we said Y is equal
to 3 and Z and Z is equal to 2 then what
would be X in that situation so if Y is
equal to 3 and Z is equal to 2 then
you're going to have this the left-hand
expression is going to be X plus 3 plus
2 it's going to be X plus 5 this
probably right over here is just going
to be 5 X plus 5 is equal to 5 and so
what plus 5 is equal to 5 well now we're
constraining that X would have to be X
would have to be equal to 0 but the
important point here 1 do you hopefully
you realize the difference between
expression and equation equation
essentially you're equating two
expressions the important thing to take
away from here is that of
variable can take on different values
depending on the context of the problem
and to hit the point home let's just
let's just evaluate a bunch of
expressions when the variables have
different values so for example if we
had the expression if we had the
expression X to the X to the Y power if
X is equal to if X is equal to five and
Y is equal to two Y is equal to two then
our expression here is going to evaluate
to well X is going now going to be five
X is going to be five Y is going to be
two it's going to be 5 to the second
power or it's going to evaluate to 25 if
we change the values if we said X if we
said X let me do that same colors if we
said X is equal to X is equal to
negative two and Y and Y is equal to
three then this expression would
evaluate two it would evaluate to let me
do it in that so it would evaluate to
negative two that's what we're going to
substitute for X now in this context and
Y is now three negative two to the third
power negative two to the third power
which is negative two times negative two
times negative 2 which is negative 8
negative 2 times negative 2 is positive
4 times negative 2 again is equal to
negative 8 is equal to negative 8 so you
see depending on the values of these
aquarii we could do even you know we
could do more complex things we could
have an expression like the square root
of x plus y and then minus minus X like
that if X is equal to let's say that X 0
is equal to 1 and y Y is equal to 8 then
this expression would evaluate to well
where every time we see an X we want to
put a 1 there so we would have a 1 there
and you would have a 1 over there and
every time you see why you would put an
8 in its place in this context we're
setting these variables so you'd see an
8 so under the radical sign you would
have a 1 plus 8 so you'd have the
principal root of 9 which is 3 so this
whole thing would sim
both I in this context when we set these
variables to be these things this whole
thing would simplify to be 3 1 plus 8 is
9 principal root of that is 3 and then
you'd have 3 minus 1 which is equal to
which is equal to 2